but overall it worked yeah and it wasn't
a great mood laughing a lot during the
crypto Cup in Miami this is the tour
finals with four players Magnus Crossing
one of them sitting in an arena in San
Francisco he will start out with the
white pieces against his big rival from
2021 Wesley so what is Magnus carlsen's
plan in this first game we are waiting
for first move we have seen him
experiment quite a lot this season with
his openings Magnus Carlsen so what do
you expect from this game David yeah as
Ivanka mentioned white starting with the
white pieces that is going to be key and
Magnus he has freestyle throughout the
year it's often as if he's rolling a
dice or something in in terms of his
opening choices but yeah I expect him to
play his
best openings the openings he's been
relying on in World Championship matches
uh for example with the Catalan or maybe
some Spanish openings because you can't
freestyle against Wesley Wesley is too
strong it's too good and he will punish
you and here we go he does open with one
E4
and I'm expecting Wesley to copy there
we go will we be heading towards the
Berlin defense that's Wesley's go-to
solid
um black opening we do see the Spanish
and will Black's other night come out it
is the Berlin defense Rock Solid stuff
so far an exchange of Pawns in the
center I actually had this position this
weekend myself as black against Yonder
to become a another commentator it was a
draw with black this is known as Rock
Solid but can Magnus break down this
defense White's Rook is kicked back both
sides of castled Wesley now offering a
trade of Rooks are you surprised Ivanka
this is known to be very level if black
knows what he's doing yeah I'm slightly
surprised because I actually expected
Magnus to take the game into more
unconventional Waters and instead we see
here quite a symmetrical position I mean
in the sense that all the pawns are on
the same side and it's just going to be
all about which pieces are better and
the players are just racing through the
moves and I get the feeling that this
isn't the most ambitious approach from
Magnus oh it's very very surprising
stuff to me at least I mean this has a
reputation this exact variation of the
Berlin has a reputation of being just
not necessarily unambitious for white
but it's minimalistic you're just aiming
for a safe position
no risk but not much reward uh
potentially and I also have experience
of this exact position against Alpha
zero a well-known computer program I was
part of a team that played against the
uh the uh AI uh Alpha zero and
we made a draw with white it's just
impossible to lose this position
essentially if you're Magnus look at the
pawn structure now completely
symmetrical and
unless he has a brand new idea up his
sleeve maybe involving these Pawn pushes
then uh I say a brand new idea it
doesn't look too impressive but uh yeah
unless Magnus has something here
feeling we're gonna head towards an
equal position
I was just gonna say get this you know
Wesley himself has played this exact
position with the white pieces to secure
draw against vesseline tapalov ah yeah
Magnus as well he's played this
variation when he only wanted to draw
against Sergey kariakin in the last
match of the 2016 World Championship
so surprised I've got to say that uh I
mean unless black does something crazy
how are you ever going to Target any
weaknesses Black's position has no
targets at all to probat White has
slightly better pieces if you look at
White's Queen it's on an open file if
you look at White's Bishops they're
slightly slightly Superior to their
counterparts on better diagonals but
it's hard to get excited about this
position it is very difficult I mean
what does Magnus Carlton have up his
sleeve who's again check in the database
I can see that Wesley has played it with
the white pieces and also the black
pieces this exact same position happened
in his game with Maxim vashir lagrav and
that was surprise surprise a draw and
they're still following that game so
I can tell you uh Wesley actually moved
the Knight to the square in front of the
king and relocated the Pieces Just to
initiate some trades yeah
two words here comfort zone and both
players are well in that comfort zone
um yeah no surprises so far in terms of
moves nothing flashy nothing uh nothing
to write home about but yeah I think
Wesley after a little bit of thought
look he's looking down right now he's
just going into recall mode he's going
to relocate the Black Knight he doesn't
choose the square you mentioned Ivanka
um moving the Knight back to the center
rather than the square to protect its
king but uh yeah still looks solid yeah
the Black Knight now has its eyes on
both sides of the board this is an ideal
Square some pressure on that black
knight from the white Bishop but again
it's defended that's hard for Magnus to
create anything still you don't have any
pawn breaks that's the problem with this
position no way to open Lines no way to
generate an attack
so if one of them
comes up with something new in this one
would that be like huge news in the
Chess World because the Berlin is just
so well tested yes and especially this
variation of the Berlin there are ways
to make the Berlin defense kind of
interesting there are ways to keep the
tension change up the pawn structure uh
create imbalances but not this line a
shift the reality right so the whole
perception of this line if Magnus
manages to kind of concoct some very
powerful novelty people I mean just look
at the position that looks totally net
level but one thing I would have to say
about these two is they do sometimes
play it very quietly I mean Wesley is
known to be pragmatic and he's happy
with draw Safety First in certain
situations and they leave the fireworks
to the later stages of the match so I
was thinking of uh there's so many times
that we've seen this particular position
from these two well not this particular
type of position but these type are very
symmetrical games and yeah so this game
is probably not going in to history as
one of the highlights from the 2022
season but we want to know today Ivanka
what the viewers look back on when
thinking of the 2022 season yeah
definitely we are asking everyone at
home what is your favorite moment from
the Melt water Champions Chester
2022 I mean there's so many fun moments
and as always you can tweet your answer
using the hashtag chess Champs and we
will feature your memories and your
Recollections and your Clips pictures or
anything you want to send us on the show
I look forward to hearing them I mean
this is tournament number nine
there's been so much action on the board
there's been so much fun in the studio
there's been drama chess drama it's been
interesting interviews so much has
happened over the past year
and for Magnus what a year has been
giving up his world championship title
the drama with the cheating allegations
I mean it's been a life-changing year
for Magnus yeah it's been a I mean it
feels like there's been drama every
single month every single tournament
there's always been a chess story um
featuring half these players actually
and um now for Magnus it's about getting
back into the chest refocusing he's
still clearly he's very ambitious and he
will want to win this tournament and um
yeah I mean that's why I love the format
of this tournament just because we will
find a winner every day of each matchup
it's as if it's knockout chess every
single day but yeah for him it's been a
up and down year and uh he'll want to
end it on the high and uh meanwhile
Wesley has been thinking for a while
and that gives us more time to focus on
our favorite moments because I
definitely don't think this game is my
favorite of the season so far we can
mention the other matchups going on Jan
Christ of Duda number two heading into
this tournament in the overall
mouthwater Champions chess tour 2022 he
is
sitting here in Poland in his home
fighting basically against pragnananda
for that second place in the tour
overall and today he is playing against
Arjun eragaisi who's been on fire over
the last couple of tournaments he is
playing from India in the middle of the
night basically 1 30 a.m in the morning
starting the tour the tournament every
day and then pragma Nanda he is also
playing from San Francisco flew all the
way from India to sit in the arena today
playing against Mohamed yarov and I bet
there's gonna be fireworks in this one
absolutely I mean Prague was famous in
the Oslo Esports for winning his matches
in three games and uh one person who he
did be in those three games is uh
Shakura mamajarov and of course Mama jar
for such an exciting confrontational
player that when they when they do meet
I mean there's just gonna be fireworks
and excitement and from what we saw of
mom yarov in the previous tournament
he's just getting better and better do
you think he's is he one of the players
do you think maybe that can compete to
win the whole tournament possibly for
Shaq consistency is the key I mean he's
synonymous with entertaining chess with
spectacular moves but uh sometimes if if
you're inclined towards sacrificing that
cam backfire and maybe that's been his
Achilles heel in throughout his career
in terms of kind of reaching the
Pinnacle of wheelchairs but yeah I mean
his his games are just a joy to watch
and I have a feeling the viewers we've
asked them the highlight of the season I
have a feeling that some of them will
mentioned games yeah they've been
amazing
and another player who's done fantastic
this season is Liam playing from his
office in Saint Louis also sitting in
the U.S he is playing against Anish giri
the fourth player in the San Francisco
Arena it's been a tough year for a niche
in the mouthwater Champions Chester we
haven't seen him in a single final what
an end it would be for him to this
season's tour to finish off with a
victory in the tour finals what chances
do you give a nice Sri Lanka he hasn't
done so well this season as you
mentioned I mean I'm thinking back to
Miami and I'm thinking he didn't he
plays seventh uh and things just seemed
to go wrong he didn't do very well in
the Oslo Esports in his match format so
I mean I I know that he will definitely
be motivated he will be looking to
improve on his game I mean but will he
be the winner
um
I really like your Niche yeah but I'm
not so sure an underdog yeah maybe it
will suit him to be an underdog
um a niche often the moments where he
doesn't make those breakthroughs and
when he is when he feels the pressure
and now there's no pressure on him
nobody actually expects him to win he's
up against Giants uh probably the two
best rapid players in the world or two
of the best uh Magnus Wesley yeah it
feels like a niche is nothing to lose
and that's often one of the top players
they perform their best
um I have a sneaky feeling he'll cause a
shock or two anishagiri
um the one problem for him maybe is the
playoffs um The Blitz format doesn't
suit his style necessarily he's not as
quick as some of the others so
um I genuinely think he has a chance but
yeah
he has to hope that a lot of things fall
in his favor I agree I mean playoffs is
definitely his weakest I mean he put out
a tweet after he lost a critical playoff
against any house iron where he was
winning quite a few games we quoted
Taylor Swift he said the problem is me
aha yep
struggle this season Anish giri but
maybe he can cause some trouble for the
other players here in the tour finals We
are following game one Magnus Carl isn't
taking a zip of maybe some energy drink
it's not a very energetic position in
game one against Wesley so the Berlin
and even as a non-chess player I know
the Berlin means
[Laughter]
well but there's one open line on the
board and a magnus's queen and the
Rooker they're taking full control
whether he can do anything with this
well very minor Advantage well that's
hot for debates yeah you control this
file uh your pieces are very good
actually your Bishop is on a great
diagonal here your light Square Bishop
points on the right side of the board
but yeah unfortunately everything is
defended for black and here I I do think
it's the first small critical moment of
the game Wesley has to be slightly
careful because Black's Rook is asleep
uh Black's Queen is a bit stuck she
doesn't really have too many squares to
go to she has to stay defending her
Knight in the center and uh the one way
that Alpha zero I mentioned earlier I
had this battle against it the way it
solved its problems for black was to
eliminate this white knight slightly
different scenario but if you eliminate
white tonight
then your position pretty much is uh
safe for example after a trade here
Waits Queen has kicked off the open file
where it has to take this way uh to
preserve his Pawn structure and now for
black I think you can just safely move
your queen
um you can bring your Rook to the center
and challenge next move uh it looks a
bit loose potentially this is why
Wesley's hesitating because Black's
Bishop is undefended but there's no way
to take advantage of this uh Black's
Knight is covered as well uh simply if
you get one more move swap off the Rooks
you're in safety so I'm expecting this
from Wesley so the reason you want to
exchange off-white tonight is because
White Knight could potentially jump into
a very nice Square in the center of the
board
um if the black queen were to move first
for example then this night jump would
be almost deadly attacking the queen
attacking the bishop if the Knight is
traded then black has traded off his
better bishop and white is able to
install a monster in the middle of the
board this bishop now peers onto these
squares on the king side where it's
Queen is ready to swoop in as well and
there might even be a checkmating attack
on the cards so uh I think this is the
key moment Wesley should and probably
will just capture this capture this
night take it off the board play safe
and not too much to worry about what do
you think Ivanka I agree with you
objectively black is absolutely fine uh
psychologically though I do think that
Wesley will be feeling the pressure
because yes I do agree with your
suggestion of trading the bishop for the
night but at the same time you're giving
white the bishop pair and potential
um attack on the right side of the board
and against the king yep so some hope of
going for the black king later on at the
moment it's pretty safe but uh yeah I
agree if anyone you would choose white
here right I would choose and does it
remind me of a position that I
commentated on with myself and Simon in
your your game in Gibraltar you'd had
something with a very similar Pawn
structure I think there were more pieces
there was another set of Rooks on the
board and I remember we went David
and then we moved on and then we came
back oh Dave is doing really well oh
well done
um Davey won a very nice game I did
against Rasmus funner a German uh German
player I think that came from uh a
French defense but if it leads to the
same porn structure essentially and
Wesley so surprises us he brings his
Queen across two squares she's nice and
safely tucked next to the black king she
still protects her Knight but she's
vulnerable to some hits maybe the white
Bishop at some point can come and attack
her
Um this can be blocked by Black's Bishop
potentially the black Bishop would jump
back and save the day so this isn't so
effective right now but that idea is on
the radar also white tonight still can
jump in
I think Magnus will be happy to see this
move despite the fact it's still Level
still balanced Magnus will have more
hope now that he can keep more pieces on
the board
the more pieces that disappear the
closer we get to that dreaded draw so uh
yeah I'm expecting this night move
otherwise Black's Rook is simply coming
across black is ready now to start
challenging the White Queen challenging
the open file if that happens draw
black is fine
so you need to create something bring
the white knight in Magnus I think that
is the only chance to to try and win
this game
okay interesting so if Magnus brings in
his Knight now
that is a sign he is feeling a little
bit ambitious yeah I mean I mean there's
so many things that could happen
actually once the night jumps into the
center so for instance if the root comes
over to pin the Knight and the queen
well you could even go Knight takes
Bishop yeah I think you'll write your
anchor I think it's a winning tactic uh
you give up the queen
and after the queen is captured as the
Visions open in between move as we call
it an uh Knight takes Bishop yep that's
a check that's the key and when the king
moves you can simply take back the black
rook and white here is up on material
you've given up your queen but you have
a rook and a bishop or you have a rook
and two Bishops for the black queen if
we do a bit of counting that's 11 The
Black Queen worth nine we're two points
up and Black's King cannot actually take
this white knight because now it is too
exposed in the center of the board and I
think it's gonna get uh checkmated or
pushed into a bad Square this black king
Now it only has two ways to go if you go
to the center of the board there's going
to be a discovered check along this file
the white Bishop moves out the way check
and winning the black queen next move
and if the black king had gone to this
side then suddenly there would be
checkmating ideas for example hitting
the king with the pawn and Checkmate on
the edge of the board so despite the
fact we're moaning about this being a
boring Berlin a draw there are still
some tactics in the air and uh some
potential tricks traps that Magnus could
set for Wesley but they all do start
with this night move that was a long
variation but it all begins with this
night move and uh I see Ivanka mentioned
black has to avoid some ideas there yeah
I think you have to move your Bishop
yeah to retreat somewhere and if you do
have to retreat then suddenly white has
another small advantage and yeah this
night beautiful and remember black
doesn't want to exchange it off for his
dark Square Bishop because the dark
squares are too weak
um you can only exchange it off for the
light squared bishop and Magnus okay he
encourages Wesley to play a move he
probably wanted to play anyway that's a
surprise to me Ivanka I've got to admit
uh what do you think of this one
it's slightly surprising because I too
was focused on the night jump I didn't
consider this small little improving
move but then again it is magnus's style
he makes the small and proven move at
the same time creates a safer Square for
the king I mean can Wesley really get
away with like trying to trade P of
pieces so for instance
to take the night yeah this looks fine
to me and the question is whether he can
bring his Rook over and try and trade
off even more pieces white has the small
advantage of the bishop pair but the
center is blocked
um yeah still take white I think but uh
yeah it's getting close to level right
now close to equal yeah and uh whilst
the players are deep in thought Emilia
castellau tells us a very fun fact
she tells us my mouse got in the way
there and again a fun little chest
tidbit for our commentators he says but
the Mechanics Institute in San Francisco
houses the oldest chess club in the US
organized in 1854 when San Fran was a
frontier Community I didn't know that
actually I did 1854 oldest chess club in
the US wow I would have thought it would
have the U.S sorry not us New York yeah
I guess there's been some very strong
players out of New York and some other
places but uh yeah shout out to Amelia
as well a chess historian uh doing some
work for fide now I think
history fronts yeah fascinating facts
and we'll pretend we need that we'll
pretend that's why we're organizing the
tournament in San Francis some great
chess history in San Francisco these two
players both on site and Tanya our
on-site reporter in San Francisco did
get a chat with both Wesley Wesley and
Magnus before the start of uh today
Magnus you've been looking forward to
this clash and how are you feeling going
into the match feeling pretty good
starting with the white pieces yeah I'm
gonna try and put some pressure on him
from the start what do you think will be
the most deciding factor in this Clash
time fair enough good luck
Wesley walking up you mentioned you're
excited about this one tell us your
feelings I am very pleased and very glad
to be back in the Melt water Champions
Jester so I said yesterday I was very
happy when they invited me for the last
one
and uh yeah I'm very
happy to play Magnus Carlsen of the best
player in the world the very first round
I want to ask you about that because
that's one matchup we're really really
looking forward to what can we expect
when the global Champion takes on the
world champion
well I mean I hope to be able to do my
best I don't know what form I'll be in I
think my best form I can compete but uh
we'll have to see which part of me shows
up today but I know I prepared hard for
it and uh we'll see what happens uh I
think also depends on what mood Magnus
is in today well I see what according to
you will be the critical factor in
today's matchup
uh well you know if a friend of the
moves I mean I I guess I've beaten
Magnus a few times before in the past
uh I'm not sure why exactly
and you know in I guess strain of the
moves would be the most important you
know whether Magnus gets a good opening
and if it gets a comfortable position or
if I get a position that I like then
I'll have good chances I guess yeah you
look calm composed and ready for the
fight yeah I hope so I hope there I am I
a bit nervous but at the same time I I'm
ready hopefully the results will show it
all the best Wesley thank you
Magnus Carlsen saying this much depends
on time that the clock will be the
critical Factor Wesley wondering what
version of himself would turn up today I
remember one word from last season solid
so and I guess it is the solid so that
has turned off today yeah that's so
solid crew yeah yeah exactly he's uh at
least adopting that strategy with black
I think that makes sense you start off
especially he mentioned the word nervous
as well if you're feeling the nerves
just kind of feel your way into the game
don't take too many risks too early
because that's when bad things happen if
you risk take if you kind of leave holes
in your defense so he's just keeping all
the pieces on the board covering all the
squares he'll try and press with white
as Ivanka mentioned if he can hold this
game and at the moment I say if because
suddenly Black's retreating suddenly
Black's pieces are going backwards it's
Magnus in move I don't really see any
way to advance kind of the attack
Advance the initiative momentum unless
you jump in to the center with white
tonight as we've been advocating for a
while but uh
for me it was fascinating the different
styles on the board of course but also
in the interviews Marcus short and sweet
yeah just not messing about and uh
Wesley taking his time maybe talking out
the nerves from his system that's true
fascinating yeah Magnus uh he uh seemed
to be in a good mood I have to say
though I thought it seemed in a very
direct move yeah to the point business
like move on to the game yep she's doing
the same on the board direct mood yeah I
mean he's playing very quickly you know
they've blitzed out the opening and now
he's taking his time and uh Wesley it
seemed to be a bit more hesitant but uh
to me he seems to have a lot of faith in
his position you know he's not making
any critical decisions he's simply
believing in his Pawn structure
believing that his position will hold
and
I'm quite concerned actually because
when one turns to do that one tends to
drift into passivity and uh Magnus wow
well that's the kind of move I like to
play unfortunately I've been punished a
lot quite quite recently by making these
type of moves he's uh grabbing as much
space as possible on the right side yeah
that move comes with uh warning attached
don't try this at home pushing Pawns in
front of your own King but Magnus as you
say he's taking control of some key
squares and we have to show the idea
behind this move because it is
a bit surprising I've got to say it
crossed my mind but I don't think I'd
have the courage to play this move that
Magnus has just chosen it's all to do
with taking Black's control of the F5
square away and the whole reason for
example let's go back one with white
wanted to jump in with his Knight he
wanted to attack this bishop this looks
very scary but black can bring his
Bishop over to challenge White's light
Square Bishop if Pieces come off the
board we're heading towards a draw so
Magnus by pushing his Pawn forward has
stopped that idea next move white wants
to jump in as he has just done the black
Rook swings across to attack the White
Queen and Magnus blocks he blocks with
his Knight and now this black Bishop
doesn't have access to this key F5
Square no more exchanges it is attacked
and probably it just has to retreat uh
you want to run away with this bishop
you can push it to this square but it
kind of gets in the way of the black
Rook it gets in the way it's staring of
all of its own pawns not a good square
at all so I recommend this bishop to
retreat it's attacked and again remember
you don't want to eliminate you don't
want to trade off your own dark squared
Bishop as black because that is a key
Defender so I think Wesley's just going
to step back and Magnus will he regret
pushing a pawn in front of the white
king the white king looking really loose
really Airy right now
I don't know it's uh you mentioned
you've been punished in this kind of
situation before so many times in my
career don't touch Pawns in front of
your king normally but if you're Magnus
you can get away with it and uh Worsley
doesn't actually Retreat the bishop to
the starting square instead he's said to
the square in front of the Zone Rook
yeah I didn't like this because as you
mentioned it looks clumsy uh it looks
like the bishop might be a tactical
Target at some point but uh at least
it's protected for now everything in
Wesley's Camp is protected look how
passive it is though the two heavy
pieces on the back rank
um these three though they look like
they're very well centralized so at the
moment it's holding but Magnus Carlson
opening up around his King maybe we will
see some action in this game after all
and the action is happening in San
Francisco where our roaming reporter
Tanya is on site what's happening Tanya
Kaya it is so much fun here to be here
and to see just happen San Francisco is
the Global Tech Hub so many smart bright
Minds so chess is just the perfect fit
and to tell us what chess is like in San
Francisco I've got a very special guest
with me it's Juliana she's the founder
of the organizer at the Bernal chess
club Juliana welcome thank you it's
great to be here it's exciting it's
super nice to have you here with us tell
us a little bit about the just scene in
San Francisco I can tell you the main
thing in San Francisco is the Mechanics
Institute the oldest chess club either
in the country or on the west coast
um that's kind of the main thing my
little corner of the San Francisco
chasing is the Bernal chess club which
happens in the Bernal Heights
neighborhood Saturday afternoons a bunch
of people get together and play it's
just kind of a good time and then on
Wednesday the fourth Wednesday of every
month we have a lecture at the library
about a historical chess games I didn't
get a chance to go to the Mechanics
Institute it is the oldest Club in the
United States a very special nice yeah
it's wonderful it's kind of where I
started playing taking a class there
it's the first time I played over the
board so it's a special place to me you
mentioned according to chess about five
years ago how did that happen I I love
solving puzzles and a friend of mine
said oh do you play chess and I said no
you know I know how the pieces move but
I don't really play and then that night
I went and did some Googling and wound
up on chess.com and started playing
against bots and then about a year later
started taking a class with human
that's awesome and tell me a little bit
about the bone and chess club because it
sounds like a really fun place where uh
do you have regulars who come in for a
game of chess a lot of regulars over the
years we've been doing it for about
three and a half years
um and some regulars come for a few
months and go and come back and some
have been there the whole time
lots of adults lots of kids and it's
just a really friendly Vibe very casual
sounds a lot of fun we've got a big
matchup today here at Juliana with
Magnus taking on Wesley are you for home
team are you supporting Wesley in this
one
um I hadn't really picked a team yet I
guess I should do that we'll see how
this game turns out all right well enjoy
your day here at the meltwater
championship store final thank you
Juliana from the Bernal chess club
telling us about the chess scene in the
city
we did see images there from this Bernal
chess club seems like the chassis in San
Francisco is just uh crazy a lot of
Chess interest in the city probably
after the Queen's Gambit everyone yeah
it's getting more and more popular
um of course inspired by the Queen's
Gambit and of course also the fact that
lockdown had when suddenly everyone was
interested in playing chess and I'm just
going to stop there because there was a
move I totally did not
expecting because it looked like he has
been baited into also opening up his
King I don't like this one I mean it
looks so risky to open up the light
squared Bishop yeah I I'm inclined to
agree whether it's a good move or a bad
move it's not Wesley style right we
mentioned pragmatic solid Safety First
all those kind of terms when we think
about Wesley's chess and this is not a
solid move yes is kicking back one
Bishop but let's see the downside Wesley
as well remember the clock he's down on
time so the downside behind this move is
that the light Square Bishop has a clear
diagonal it has a clear Target it's only
one piece attacking right now Black's
King is however gonna feel the heat
along that diagonal and uh the positive
the one positive to this push is that
white other Bishop is kicked back and uh
Magnus now he's doing a bit of
calculating I don't really think he has
any alternatives other than moving this
bishop I'm expecting it to retreat uh
it's unclear which squares best you can
choose from this Square this square or
even the whole way back Bishops are long
range pieces so it would make some sense
to retreat the bishop the whole way back
um I'm inclined to drop back to this
Square just to protect the white Rook
White's Rook was a bit loose I'm
wondering whether Magnus has other ideas
in mind the White Knight for example
could jump out the way but no the bishop
was attacked and he does retreat the
whole way back so he's safe here he
won't get hit by the Black Knight
jumping anywhere but Wesley has some
measuring to do I was going to say maybe
the black queen can act as a Defender
around her King but first the bishop
drops back and this is really mysterious
stuff maybe it's genius though from
Wesley he's getting ready to kick back
White's best piece
it looks so counterintuitive so
unnatural but this is why these guys are
the best in the world they find these
really odd looking unorthodox moves
which do have concrete ideas behind them
and they're so good at calculating that
they realize yes it's ugly but it works
and uh yeah it takes a very very strong
player to put aside that prejudice but
aside the Aesthetics and actually
where's White's night going if black
gets this Pawn push it's going to get
kicked back and suddenly Magnus will be
on the retreat what do you think Ivanka
is there a way to take advantage of this
loosening this weakening of Black's
position
has to be now and I'm thinking you've
got to strike when the Iron's hot and
I'm thinking push my Pawn forward the F
pawn move it two squares and try to
liberate the dark Square Bishop as well
yeah for example black really shouldn't
touch this one really shouldn't capture
it because suddenly the bishop jumps
back to where it came from and uh yes
the white Bishop has lost a couple of
moves but in the meantime blacks King
protection especially along the G file
has been completely destroyed so yeah I
love that move I've got to say but it
comes with some risk attached again any
pawn pushes right they leave weak
squares and the problem with this Pawn
push is later on not right now but later
on this Square might be available a very
juicy Square for the Black Knight and uh
I guess Wesley might have ideas in mind
for example of challenging the white
knight kicking this one back and it will
all depend on whether this works for
black it does look like it's hanging by
a thread but the evaluation bar above
the board does say that black is just
about fine so is Magnus feeling
aggressive he's shown some hints of
question so far if he really wants to
push really wants to attack he'll throw
the spawn forward but three minutes now
for Magnus he said time would be the key
and it is time and pressure I love this
type of position actually it's very
subtle sophisticated chests
and uh well it always starts that way
and then it evolves into just a mess a
bit later on rather like my games and I
know he he moves his Knight back I did
not expect that because I thought once
the the fireworks had been started that
you needed to continue that way you've
got to be consistent but uh the mark of
a great player is to be flexible and
Magnus now just saying let's fight okay
he's going for another Pawn first Harry
the H1 it is the H porn you wish Simon
could be here to enjoy that move yeah we
missed the ginger GM uh hopefully he'll
join us at some point but
um yeah in the spirit of Simon Williams
in the spirit of alpha zero as well that
we mentioned earlier throwing the H Pawn
forward to destabilize black structure
this has two points firstly you're
attacking black stronghold the pawn
that's actually keeping Black's position
together and you're attacking this Pawn
on G5 and if the pawn is captured then
whites Knight happily recaptures
suddenly black has isolated pawns so
even long term even if black survives
the upcoming attack there will be
structural problems
um normally in this type of situation
you never ever want to capture away from
the center which black would be doing
you want to kind of protect your
stronghold which he's done Wesley so but
this is loose as well oh I was going to
say something David actually I just
checked the computer evaluations and
Wesley's last pawn move is a huge
mistake there was only really one way to
maintain the balance and that was to
take a risk take a Gamble and actually
jump in with a knight to the center okay
so black should have jumped in with the
Knight and why is this a mistake Ivanka
is it because of this move uh retreating
the White Queen White has a threat bring
the queen to H7 this would be Checkmate
the black king would be trapped the
White Queen would be defended by her
Bishop in the center so massive threat
on the board black has to now play your
idea has to jump in and Magnus is simply
trying to erode this Knight he isn't
even interested in grabbing a pawn you
could capture this Knight and win a pawn
in the process but Bishops are the key
pieces in this position so white knight
is recruited attacking the Black Knight
on e4
can he hold it together there's a huge
threat of pushing this Pawn forward
hitting the Black Knight the Knight is
pinned if it moves out the way wherever
it goes then remember this checkmating
idea the white Queen's swooping up to H7
trapping the black king
um yeah you've got to be really careful
as Wesley so right now evaluation bar
still says it's equal it does block this
diagonal after the White Knight Retreat
remember this was a threat so he pushes
the pawn uh this diagonal is blocked but
can he survive Wesley
it's become in Practical terms difficult
for black definitely and uh you can just
see that the weaknesses around the black
king are starting to Creak and also
White's pieces springing forward to life
and uh well I'm guessing
where Magnus must be calculating what's
going to happen if he Trace off forms
yeah so first thing move that you look
for in this type of position checks
captures threats direct moves
um he was in a direct mood in the
interview Magnus Carlson he does indeed
trade off this Pawn you could make an
argument next move as well for trying to
get rid of this Black Knight does he
trade it off yes he does he's removing
Defenders black strongest pieces and uh
which way is Wesley going to exchange
even though pieces are disappearing from
the board it's still the black king
that's the target it's still Black's
king that's weak let's go back to the
place it is heating up both down now to
three minutes
and fireworks are ahead this one is
started slowly but it's been simmering
for a while what is that the Magnus is
drinking energy drink maybe and uh he
will need energy in order to break
through and win this game Wesley's
definitely on the defensive now that's
black that's actually kind of shocking
magna's been very much on the water
while playing chess for I like the past
what five years yeah you're right
staying very much away from sugar and
coughing and stuff like that
this is a huge change if it is for
example an energy drink
and you can quit the orange juice right
I thought that would be pretty healthy
but no uh water it was yeah and
meanwhile a set of Rooks have left the
board and still I would say that Magnus
has the preferable position because
Black's King is so weak and also taking
a look at those two pawns there I mean
they are just setting targets yeah lacks
Pawn on the e-file that's just captured
and that black G Pawn in front of the
black king isolated pawns can be
weaknesses and we would class this as an
end game now right I guess ah there
aren't that many pieces on the board the
Queens are still on but it's basically a
queen end game just with Bishops and
despite the fact we're in an end game
still a lot of life left Magnus as well
is the master essentially in end games
not many people can compete maybe Wesley
can in certain games but this one will
be difficult Magnus needs to create some
threats before the black queen gets into
the game and he shuffles up just one
square with the White Queen she's
hinting at coming in on a diagonal going
towards the black king delivering some
tracks also stopping the black queen
from jumping begin 20 squares I think a
queen exchange might favor White
this type of position because black
spawns are so weak and apparently no
drama in the drinking situation it's
sparkling water
but drama on the board you think this
will end up where the winner the bar is
very much over to Magnus Carlson's side
I'm not sure whether it will end up with
a winner but there's only going to be
one person trying for the Victory and
that's Magnus Carlson and I just love
this little queen move that he's played
you know mobilizing the queen getting
ready to launch some checks and at the
same time it's still hinting at
attacking those pawns and Wesley
stepping forward with his King yeah
stepping out into No Man's Land
potentially walking into some checks
whether there's a result in this game or
I mean is it decisive result in this
game or not look at the other games as
well just below the player's cameras we
can see Duda has a winning Advantage but
but earlier he was actually losing and
manager of turning things as well in his
favor against Prague so a lot of drama
in game one of the finals Magnus what a
calm move I would have been too tempted
I would have swooped in with the White
Queen given some checks maybe that
wouldn't have come to anything though
and instead Magnus is using every single
piece inviting everything to the party
the white king steps forward but
according to the computer this has blown
some of the advantage White's King is
slightly vulnerable to checks itself now
and uh okay what do you think of this
decision uh Ivanka stepping forward with
the white king now Magnus going after
some Pawns
surprising surprising I mean I didn't
expect it but I still think it's great
for white and there we see Magnus
mobilizing the bishop but the big
question is how to improve I mean white
does have the potential actually to push
some pawns there on the left side and
perhaps use those pawns as a decoy to
take the black queen away from the
protection of her King yeah and uh
Wesley his King is definitely the more
vulnerable of the two so he matches up
the board looks counter-intuitive but
actually there's no checks available now
the king wants to hide on light squares
the black king both Kings actually
because both Bishops aren't dark squares
and so Magnus will he go for that idea
now I think he might Ivanka I think you
might be right White's pawns on the
queen side you're a bit stuck elsewhere
so why not push them
but uh Wesley has potentially the idea
of bringing the black queen across two
squares to F5 offering a trade of Queens
if the Queen's come off now because
Black's King is so active
I'll probably just drop probably fine
for black I think Wesley might be over
the worst maybe Magnus which was trying
to be a bit too clever a bit too
sophisticated by bringing his King up
white king
not necessarily on a great square and he
could have used that one extra move to
get active with the White Queen
it's all about timing maybe Magnus has
missed the moment yeah I
potentially I I think so but still there
are questions to be asked I mean Magnus
first of all has to give his Queen a
purpose and the white king like you said
you know needs to be improved ideally
I'd like to actually move the king to
where the queen is standing and then put
the queen somewhere where she covers all
the checks ah I think Wesley has a key
idea up his sleeve as well so Magnus
he's ticking under one minute we'll come
back to the players in a moment but uh
here Magnus I think his plan was to
swoop in with the White Queen create
some pressure start attacking some pawns
um he Retreats actually but here
Wesley's idea was to offer a queen
exchange giving up the black bishop and
now suddenly after this check White's
King has no Escape if you go to the
right the black queen follows you with a
check if you go to the left the black
queen follows you again if you go back
the black queen swoops in and the
position would be a draw repetitioner
moves No Escape Perpetual check so
Magnus his idea wasn't quite working it
would have led to a draw simply so he
had to retreat he stepped back with the
White Queen but the white Queen's not
great now and Wesley takes the
opportunity
Ford himself suddenly I'm a bit worried
for Magnus the momentum is in Black's
favor and suddenly an end game these
pawns might be dangerous these pawns
marching down on the left side of the
board
I think it might be time to try and uh
bail out to a draw yeah uh definitely
it's uh getting double edged again
because both sides have that possibility
to create past pawns I'm always wary now
of pushing past pushing Pawns in end
games after sitting next to you for so
long I'm like oh you should be patient
and there we see a Magnus swooping with
the queen and I mean there has been
consequences to Wesley's ambitious porn
moves there because if white were to
make the right set of Trades it might be
the the D4 Pawn that is the winner yep
that white d-pawn blockaded by The Black
Queen right now but it is a past Pawn
long term I'm wondering whether firstly
Wesley can just lock things up he's
closed down the queen side everything's
blocked now on the left side but I was
wondering whether he can still try this
idea of Swinging The Black Queen across
and going for some tracks he didn't go
for that
the now Magnus running away with the
white king that's a preemptive Retreat
again Magnus has done this a few times
this game he he knows the opponent's
plan Black's Queen was going to come in
with some tracks as we showed so he's uh
running away yeah I like this King movie
I was being on my radar now for the last
few moves I've been thinking what
happens if the white king runs all the
way to the left and then when the queen
trade does happen
whites is primed for that yeah did you
notice Wesley shook his head and he
exhaled he did not look happy
I think he maybe regrets not going for
the draw not bringing that black queen
towards the white king earlier now that
white king is running as you mentioned
that way and uh okay a check with the
white king continue its Journey if it
gets pushed back towards the right side
of the board then the Black Wing will go
back where it came from your idea I got
a runner a renegade King and uh yeah the
king is uh coming in and now Magnus is
uh free with the queen to give a few
checks and remember that weak Pawn you
know especially the E4 Pawn
it's Target yeah Black's Bishop is also
Under Fire right now Black's Bishop no
longer protected
does Wesley have to go back with his
Queen where he came from that would be a
passive Retreat and negative move both
players down around the one minute mark
this one is going to be a scramble
who can hold their nerve Wesley
mentioned he was nervous before the game
could that play a factor it's still
black fighting for the draw even after
everything even with the computer
evaluation at 0.0 and Black's Bishop
just moves very calm it is very calm
that is a White Queen to give a check
yeah and there's suddenly the E4 Pawn is
up for grabs
I mean the black king has to step
forward yeah there we go it's running oh
that's out in the open yeah exactly very
vulnerable now more checks inevitable
another check
the black king goes back where it came
from the problem for white is if the
black king sits on light squares only
the queen can attack white cannot
combine his Queen and Bishop on the
light squares White's Bishop is a bit of
a passive piece so I think Wesley might
have found the best way to defend looked
scary again these top players they're so
good at weighing up the danger weighing
up the risk Wesley hates risk but he
knew that his King is safe enough for
now
yeah what do you think draw Ivanka
or will Magnus can Magnus play for more
he can repeat the moves he can continue
giving checks and that would force a
draw instantly
would you push forward with a white
d-pawn it's it's hard that might come
with some more
downsides
gives another check check and I do like
the idea of pushing the d-pawn take the
risk perta Wesley under some pressure
yeah but Wesley
looking confident Magnus down to 20
seconds it's quite a big time difference
suddenly and in Practical terms maybe
it's safer to just get the draw move on
to the next game but Magnus will be
reluctant
and uh okay we see the position repeat
itself three times and we do have a
result
it's over game one started with